multiversal Madness epic conspiracies
and a villain who make Thanos look like
Baby Groot here's what's happening in
the next phase of the MCU while phase 4
might be one part of the Multiverse Saga
that encompasses phases four through six
it didn't actually explore too much of
the mcu's Multiverse sure the Multiverse
might have been a core element to films
and shows like Spider-Man no way home
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness and Loki but few of the other
phase 4 projects went anywhere near the
concept now however with Kang the
Conqueror being formally introduced in
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania the
Multiverse Saga can really start to live
up to its name although Kang's dastardly
plans have yet to be revealed if the
comics are anything to go by then it's
possible that he's building a
multiversal army made up of his own
variants what he's doing in the quantum
realm is anyone's guess but it's
probably no coincidence that Avengers
end game revealed that this tiny reality
acts as a convenient form of time travel
of course Loki is getting a second
season in phase five two so we're bound
to get some more Multiverse fun there as
well outside of those two projects well
it's anyone's guess but here's hoping we
get to delve even deeper into the Marvel
Multiverse at this point it's pretty
obvious that the MCU is building up Kang
the Conqueror as its next big bad in
phase six Avengers the Kang Dynasty will
likely see Kang take on the mcu's
Mightiest Heroes in a huge cinematic
brawl and he's likely to play a key role
in that movie's follow-up Avengers
Secret Wars Kang didn't have much of a
role in Phase 4 since we only met one of
his variants in a single episode of Loki
but he's set to make his proper
on-screen debut in Phase 5. Kang will be
the main villain in Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and he's likely to have at
least some kind of presence in season 2
of Loki since he was heavily teased in
the first season's finale outside of
that it's tough to say where Kang will
appear next but with films like the
Marvels and Guardians of the Galaxy vol
3 further exploring Marvel Cosmos it's
certainly possible that more characters
will start to interact with Kang or his
variants phase 4 might have simply
hinted at the rise of the Conqueror but
Phase 5 will plant the seeds for him to
become the mcu's next big threat
[Music]
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania the
first entry in Phase 5 hits theaters
this coming February the movie's Fun
Size Heroes will be joined by Scott
Lang's daughter Cassie as they Traverse
the quantum realm to interact with some
strange and dangerous new entities as
you now know Ant-Man and Company will
run into Kang at some point but details
about the rest of quantumania have been
pretty scarce and Kang certainly isn't
going to be the only villain for Scott
to fight for one thing Bill Murray is
set to appear as a minor antagonist
while rumors have suggested that Corey
stahl's Ant-Man character Darren cross
might be returning as the mcu's very own
version of Modoc however it turns out
this latest Adventure into the quantum
realm will play a key role in set the
stage for Phase 5 of the MCU Marvel's
secret invasion is easily one of the
biggest series coming to Disney Plus in
2023 the show should deliver some solid
conspiracy Thrills which is only fitting
for an adaptation of one of Marvel's
most iconic storylines for the first
time in the MCU Nick Fury will assume a
leading role as he deals with a Rebels
sect of skrulls led by the mysterious
gravic who have infiltrated various
levels of human society along with
Jackson reprising his role as Fury
several MCU stalwarts are set to return
including Don Cheadle Ben Mendelson Kobe
smalters and Martin Freeman secret
Invasion could also have a significant
impact on the MCU going forward as the
comic book on which it's based is famous
for having revealed the scroll's
identities behind some of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes this series will also
introduce a host of new characters
played by such esteemed actors as Emilia
Clarke and Olivia Coleman clearly the
Marvel universe is facing a cataclysmic
alien Envision who knows what kind of
chaos it could bring right off the back
of the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special James Gunn and the Guardians are
set to deliver their third and final
adventure together on the big screen
with Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. in
this installment Peter Quill and Company
fight to protect one of their own while
dealing with new friends and foes
although Marvel hasn't given up too much
info regarding the latest Guardians
Adventure the first teaser trailer gave
us enough to chew on with the high
evolutionary appearing as the film's
main villain and the debut of Lila an
anthropomorphic otter it's safe to say
that volume 3 will likely focus more on
Rocket's Origins and see him collide
with his creator the film will also
introduce Adam Warlock who plays a major
role in Marvel lore and will probably
become one of the most powerful energies
in the MCU
I think I shall call him
Adam
more importantly this will likely be the
last time we see this guardian's team
together Dave Batista has publicly said
that this is his last Guardians film so
there will likely be some kind of
send-off for Drax and many fans have
speculated that Rocket won't be getting
out alive either either way volume 3 is
shaping up to be a fitting and emotional
final part in the Guardians of the
Galaxy Trilogy Echo made her debut back
in Hawkeye in which she acted as a minor
antagonist for Clint Barton and Kate
bishop and confronted her adoptive
father Kingpin now she's set to star in
her own series on Disney plus that will
continue to flesh out her character and
see her rise as a new hero in the MCU
while fans are still eagerly awaiting
their first look at the upcoming series
there are some details we know about the
show including the return of two fan
favorite characters the series will see
Maya Lopez return to her Oklahoma
Hometown to confront her past and
reconnect with her Native American Roots
finding new inspiration as kingpin's
shadow looms over her along with Vincent
de navrio returning his Kingpin Charlie
Cox is also set to reprise his role as
Matthew Murdock obviously this is a
pretty big deal for fans of these two
characters and it seems that Echo will
help set the stage for Daredevil's
full-blown return later in Phase 5. Loki
is the first live-action MCU show in
Disney plus to get a second season and
it's set to return in Phase five with
the titular god of Mischief getting into
more Multiverse hijinks the series will
pick up after Sylvie's hasty decision to
kill he who remains forever altering the
timelines and sending Loki back to a
Time variance Authority ruled by a Kang
variant we also know that Tom Hiddleston
will be returning alongside Sofia
dimartino and many familiar faces from
the first season not much is known about
what Loki's next adventure has in store
but there's plenty to theorize about
given how the last season ended for
example the last couple of episodes saw
Loki interact with more variants of
himself so it stands to reason that
series will Explore More of the
Multiverse and its many Divergent
timelines if season 2 of Loki can match
the same energy and ambition of the
first season then MCU fans are
definitely in for a treat although Loki
died back at the beginning of Avengers
Infinity War he's been alive and
thriving in a separate timeline during
the events of Loki however with the MCU
now directly tackling the growing
Multiverse it's worth wondering if
there's an opening for Loki to return to
the main timeline at some point during
phase 5 without knowing the full details
of season 2 of Loki it's tough to say at
the moment but there's certainly reason
to believe that it might eventually
happen
surprise at this point it's probably
fair to say that Loki is one of the most
experienced MCU characters when it comes
to traversing the Multiverse as such he
could be a vital Ally in the battle
against Kang of course Loki's return to
the main timeline may be saved for phase
six but even if that's the case the
ending of season 2 of Loki might set him
off in that direction and hey it'd be
worth it to see Thor's reaction alone
Captain Marvel made a few small
appearances throughout phase four but
she's gearing up for a big cinematic
return in the upcoming coming movie the
Marvels which will see your star
alongside two Rising forces in the MCU
Monica Rambo and Kamala Khan Cosmic
[Music]
the Marvels is going to be a pivotal
Phase 5 film not only because it sees
these three Heroes coming together for
the first time but also because it'll
likely tackle some of the franchise's
biggest hanging story threats Monica
last appeared when she suddenly gained
Powers at the end of one division her
return will likely see her fully utilize
these new abilities in battle and if the
story takes the same path as the comics
she'll likely take the name Photon or
Spectrum the Marvels will also reveal
why Kamala and Carol switched places at
the end of Miss Marvel we don't know any
particular plot details to delve into at
the moment but it has been announced
that velvet Buzz saws Sally Ashton will
be playing the movie's villain although
Marvel Studios has faced some production
obstacles with its upcoming reboot of
Blade the film is still set to be a part
of phase five blade will see mahershala
Ali step into the big shoes of Wesley
Snipes performance as the titular
vampire Hunter new director Jan dimash
recently stepped in to helm the film
after bassan tariq's sudden exit while
bringing on a new writer in Michael
starbury to help pen a fresh script
according to Chloe Zhao that was blade
who we heard in the post-credits scene
of eternals meaning that Dane Whitman
could also show up in the Standalone
movie setting the stage for him to
finally become Black Knight meanwhile
blade will likely be one of the mcu's
most horror tinged projects to date with
all the Bloodshed you'd expect from the
daywalkers battles against Earth's
vampire hordes although phase 4
introduced plenty of Heroes nunners
highly anticipated or beloved by fans as
blade whose movie is easily one of the
most eagerly awaited Phase 5 projects
phase 4 touched on some of Marvel's
horror themed Heroes including Moon
Knight and werewolf by night and of
course Phase 5 will formally introduce
blade to the MCU so is it possible that
we'll see some of these characters
Collide it's not totally out of the
realm of possibility since these Heroes
and anti-heroes match each other's tone
well they might even make a splash in
The Wider MCU at the moment the
franchise's horror side has more or less
in its own offshoot and it's not clear
where exactly certain characters could
fit into the mcu's future since the end
of Moon Knight fans have been wondering
whether we would see the titular hero
again and Oscar Isaac has promised that
Moon Knight's time in the MCU is far
from over we haven't heard from him
since though and there's no indication
that Jack Russell man thing or Elsa
Bloodstone will be back anytime soon
either still blades emergence could
offer a tent pull around which Marvel's
horrific heroes and villains could
revolve and the rise of the mcu's scary
side might even lead to some other
long-awaited character instructions good
luck
I'll be
rotting for you
black panther wakanda forever didn't
just introduce a new black panther to
the MCU it also brought in another
promising young hero Riri Williams it
wasn't exactly a grand introduction and
while Dominique Thorne certainly kills
it in the roll and does get a suit to
fly around in Riri doesn't get enough of
the spotlight to make her Mark however
that's all set to change with the
upcoming Disney plus series ironheart
the series which takes place after the
events of wakanda forever will see Riri
return to her hometown of Chicago to
build a new suit and interact with a new
villain known as the hood aside from
that not much is known about ironheart
but it'll very likely see Riri fully
become her titular superhero Persona
after that maybe she'll join the Young
Avengers or turn up in the upcoming
armor Wars movie Whatever riri's future
has in store it's a safe bet that she's
set to become one of the mcu's most
popular Heroes after multiple
appearances throughout the MCU Charlie
Cox's Daredevil is finally ready to lead
his own series Once More with Daredevil
born again the show will not only see
Matthew Murdoch return to his role as
protector of Hell's Kitchen but also the
return of Vincent d'onofrio's Kingpin as
his Nemesis with Daredevil having
already met so many MCU characters and
the series Hefty 18 episode order
there's a lot of potential for
Crossovers and cameos since born again
is a soft reboot of Daredevil rather
than an explicit continuation of the
Netflix series it's tough to say if many
or any of the characters from that
series will appear but it does open the
door for other MCU Heroes to turn up
She-Hulk Echo and even Spider-Man could
play a role in the series and who knows
if any wild cards might appear Matt
Murdoch's cameo in no way home certainly
shows that the MCU isn't afraid to pair
the mighty web Slinger and the devil of
Hell's Kitchen together and in Alliance
with Daredevil could be the perfect way
to have Spidey finally meet Kingpin the
MCU is never afraid to bring back old
enemies but Phase 5 in particular will
see many old villains rise again to take
on new forms and wreak more Havoc
the name's Agatha Harkness lovely to
finally meet you dear
for example one division's fan favorite
villain will get her time in the
spotlight with the upcoming Disney plus
series Agatha covet of chaos plot
details are currently under wraps for
the series which has added Aubry Plaza
as a villain and it remains to be seen
how the show will impact the MCU going
forward meanwhile a villain from 2008's
the Incredible Hulk is also set to make
a return in the MCU Tim Blake Nelson
Samuel Stearns will follow his comic
book storyline and become the leader in
Captain America New World Order
Thunderbolts will also see a host of
previous villains come together on a new
team including some of the most Sinister
and dangerous foes to have appeared in
the previous space Sam Wilson soars once
more as the new Captain America in the
upcoming movie Captain America New World
Order
the only Power I have
is that I believe we can do better the
film will see Sam continue to Traverse
the world as Captain America and face
off against a new threat in the form of
the leader other familiar faces from the
Falcon of the Winter Soldier will return
including Danny Ramirez as Joaquin
Torres and Carl lumbly as Isaiah Bradley
New World Order will feature Harrison
Ford who has stepped into the role of
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross after William
hurt's sudden passing earlier this year
it will also bring in another new Young
heroine in Sabra a super-powered mutant
from Israel the Cloverfield Paradox
director Julius Ona will be behind the
camera for the fourth Captain America
movie which will feature some of the
conspiracy Thriller Vibes of Captain
America the Winter Soldier fans of the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier will also
be looking forward to this one which
could be a promising start to Sam's
tenure as Captain America in the MCU a
new team is forming in the MCU at the
tail end of phase five the Thunderbolts
after Valentino alleged of Fontaine
appeared across space for to gradually
build her team of ragtag heroes and
villains they'll take action at last
with the upcoming movie Thunderbolts the
titular team will consist of Elena
Bulova Red Guardian Taskmaster the
winter soldier ghost U.S agent and
Fontaine herself they'll be led by
Thaddeus Ross plot details have been
kept under wraps so far but the MCU has
been building toward this team up
throughout the previous phase
interestingly the movie will also focus
on villains such as Taskmaster and ghost
who barely played significant roles in
their own movies more importantly
Thunderbolts will bring Harrison Ford's
Thaddeus Ross to the Fort if the movie
follows the comics closely his character
could be taken in a very intriguing
Direction the mcu's long-awaited reboot
of Fantastic Four is on the way and
while the film won't debut until the
start of phase six will likely get our
first tints from them sometime in Phase
five at the moment there are no plot
details for Fantastic Four and there
haven't been any casting announcements
either but it was confirmed recently
that one division director Matt shackman
will now be helming the film we've
already seen one variant of Mr Fantastic
show up in Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness although at this
stage it's very unlikely that this
version will reappear likewise prolific
rumors about Dr Doom showing up in Black
Panther wakanda forever also prove false
it's tough to say we're a fantastic hint
or Cameo might occur in the near future
but as production begins ramping up for
the February 2025 film the arrival of
Marvel's first family in the MCU will no
doubt Loom large over phase five